he laughs he likes to sit he likes to
look out the window he'll sit already
with me and watch
sports for 45 minutes he'll sit and
watch baseball he's four and a half
months oh you're already making him
watch wrestling no yes are you oh yeah
do you still watch a lot of wrestling I
do but you were spotted somewhere I read
right it's some I was like that's right
I was just at Smackdown I was just at
Smackdown in Salt Lake City you love
this [ __ ] I do you've always loved
wrestling and now you're on a wrestling
show all right now I'm on a wrestling
show but now I get to go back through on
peacock and I get to go and watch all
the old Royal Rumbles with him I'm just
gonna take him through the 1980s and all
my favorite stuff who's your favorite
wrestler 80s of all time
Hulk Hogan you loved Hulk I did I know
it's not it's a sort of a popular answer
everyone retrospectively is like it was
Jake the Snake Roberts not always her
the giant well I liked Andre the Giant
too but I only knew him through the
prism of his him being a bad guy because
him
him going around the territories and
being a good guy for all those years was
before my time so I didn't know right uh
do you are you is there any anxiety with
you wondering hey is keel's gonna get
picked up for a third season uh you know
what am I gonna do what's next do you
get that sort of feeling you have to be
doing something or you're just sort of
enjoying this moment I'm enjoying this
moment a lot right now actually to a
point where I don't know that I've ever
been as settled and comfy in my own skin
as I am at right at this right at this
particular moment I'm really enjoying it
there's it
I wouldn't say anxiety but uh we are
going through a process right now where
Stars was acquired by Lionsgate in 2016.
and they are now in the process of
as best I understand it untangling that
partnership I have no idea what that
means yeah by the way but again from the
little of it that I understand
as the as they are untangling everything
they are figuring out which assets
belong to whom so as a result we wrapped
filming on the first of July and we
don't have a premiere date let alone a
trailer let alone an indication of
season three
I know that I know that there are
meetings that are starting to happen
about writing for season three really
but in the normal in the normal order of
things we would have more information
than right it's been two months it's
been a couple of months three months
it's been three months and no Trail or
no so does that does that worry you have
you talked to Pete Siegel have you
talked I mean I just talked with Mike
O'Malley this morning who's our
showrunner and he's like I'm at it he's
like I'm putting the finishing touches
on eight which is our final episode this
year so again that's how far along we
are in the process
it's amazing I I'd be worried if I
thought that if I didn't think the
season was spectacular I think the
season's it's better than one 100 way
better more action
more story more scope more I'm
you know I I personally think that that
I went up a level for a variety of
reasons and I'm I'm incredibly happy
with my performance and and the action
and the storytelling and just the I
don't know it was just and it also felt
more like a cohesive season because we
actually shot it
in order and
you know we're subject to
covid hiccups but not coveted
catastrophes right